you mentioned Wall Street in your speech
today and Wall Street got booed I'm
wondering what for you the proper role
of Wall Street is in our society very
different role we need a financial
system in which banks are making
affordable loans to small and medium
sized businesses where they're part of
the productive the economy helping us
create jobs but Wall Street essentially
is is a world unto itself which has its
own goals coming up with incredibly
complicated financial tools and their
job is to make a handful of people much
wealthier I think when you have so much
concentration of wealth and power in the
hands of a few I honestly believe that
we should do with Teddy Roosevelt would
have done notice that you got to break
them up with the Dow go up and the
Sanders administration I think women
have yeah it matters to me but I think
when you have a productive economy with
small and medium-sized businesses on
making profits where people are working
yeah I think the doubt will do just fine
okay
when asking about some macroeconomic
things you've got some candidates
talking about 4% growth GDP is up a
little bit but under Sanders
administration again what would you
aspire to for GDP yeah four percent
growth well you know I think what we
need it's it's you can't pick a number
to it but what I believe is if we invest
in rebuilding our crumbling
infrastructure we've got a trillion
dollar bill that would create up to 13
million jobs if we have a financial
system that makes loans affordable to
small and medium sized businesses I
think we can substantially reduce
unemployment today we've got to also
focus on youth unemployment which I
mentioned is just off of the charts so
my job is to as president is to create
as many many jobs as we can and that's
what so if you did that if you got if
you were like didn't you pass the
infrastructure you're talking about
education all the things you're talking
about what would GDP be like what would
your goal be what's America what's
reasonable for America is the
substantially lower real unemployment in
America and raise wages for people that
is what my focus is you want to spend a
lot more you want to raise taxes on some
people I'm interested in what you want
to cut what are the big items in the
federal budget currently you'd like to
cut look
truth is there is as my conservative
friends point out a lot of waste in
federal government and we can run a much
more efficient government I find it
interesting that the only major federal
agency that has not been able to audit
itself or have an independent order or
it is the Department of Defense and what
I can tell you is that virtually every
major defense contractor has either
reached settlement with the United
States government because of allegations
of fraud or in fact have been convicted
of fraud you have massive costs overrun
so one area that I think we could take a
hard look at is the defense budget to
make it a much more efficient operation
than it is are there any specific
current weapons programs you'd like to
eliminate or scale back not at this well
they're all but I can you name one today
can I name there are a variety of weapon
systems that are designed to fight the
Cold War I think we spend too much money
on nuclear weapons for example I do not
believe that we need all of the aircraft
carriers that some are suggesting what
about the bases in Europe do you think
we need as many base well troops in
Europe it's a good point that's a good
point at a time when we have countries
around the world and in Europe there are
in many ways have a stronger middle
class then we do I think it is important
to review the degree to which we have to
defend countries whose middle class is
stronger than ours are there any
specific bases overseas or in the US
you'd like to see close that's a good
question I can't give you a specific
answer at this point okay
beyond depending on where I know you've
just talked about maybe some cuts are
there any domestic programs of
significant size that you'd like I think
we have gotten subsidizing corporate
agriculture for example that is an area
that we will pay specific sectors you
would point out to say that there well
the dairy sugar
well dairy most of the way I would look
at it is if you're into large corporate
farming you really do not need subsidies
from the federal government I am a
supporter of family farms not just dairy
in my own state of Vermont but I would
like to see a strengthened and resilient
family Foam situation in America where
people can maintain their family funds
under the eight years of a Sanders
administration what would happen to the
national debt would you aspire to lower
it sure and you are looking as you
probably know at one of the major
deficit hawks in the United States
Congress the estimate is that the wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan will end up
costing us somewhere between four and
six trillion dollars I voted against
those wars I voted against the Medicare
Part D prescription drug program are
written by the pharmaceutical industry
so and also I have voted against many of
the tax breaks that Bush and Obama have
allowed the wealthy to enjoy a double
back together
I am a deficit Hawk so the question is
yes the national debt of eighteen
trillion dollars is a serious problem
the question is you do not do as the
Republicans want to do and that is move
toward a balanced budget on the backs of
the elderly the children the sick and
the poor you do ask the wealthiest
people in this country to stop paying
their fair share of taxes you do not go
to war without paying for it again the
notion of being a deficit Hawk I
understand what you're saying I know you
want to do raise additional revenue but
you also want to spend a lot more I know
the journal did a story that you dispute
the specifics up but there's no doubt
you're for increased spending in a lot
of areas increased revenue in some areas
but would you would you and your first
budget for instance submit a balanced
budget no no you could not do that but
let me just say a few things and and the
Wall Street Journal was dead wrong on a
number of points that they were making
when you talk they suggest that I think
I'm spending 18 trillion over a ten-year
period 15 of that was on health care
what they forgot to say is that when we
move toward a national health care
program the kind of program that exists
in every other major country on earth
the cost per capita on health care will
go significantly down so yes
taxes would go up and you would not have
to pay private health insurance as an
individual or as a business you say your
deficit Hawk but then you just said oh I
gotta pee but you say you said your
deficit hawk but then you say of course
you wouldn't submit a balance
what I said is compared to my Republican
friends who talked a whole lot about
sure the deficit who then go to war and
don't pay for it give huge tax breaks to
billionaires don't pay for it or offset
it yes I am but don't worry about your
view of the importance as a deficit Hawk
up so you were president for eight years
would you aspire to year by year bring
down the deficit depends on the economic
situation I think the deficit is an
important issue but I'll tell you what I
think is a more important issue what is
more important is creating millions of
jobs that our people need and rebuilding
our infrastructure making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
making sure that we do not continue to
have the highest rate of childhood
poverty of any major country on earth
those issues in fact are more important
to me than the deficit but the deficit
is important okay again you talked about
cutting defense and you talked about
cutting some corporate welfare or
something I think there's a lot of waste
in the agricultural Department is there
anything specific you can point to there
well we are subsidizing large corporate
farming in general and I don't think
that large corporate corporations need
our support all right I want to finish
asking about some funner stuff we
thought policy I did enough policy for
all right all right cover of Time
magazine your first time on the cover
yes I know every time I like to get a
sense of whether you can actually get
excited is this exciting to you yeah on
the cover time degree time as a kid yeah
it was around me and it was you know we
sort of course yeah so that's pretty
good what else has happened lately
that's been exciting what happened is
that we have really had some great
meetings in South Carolina in Iowa are
the locations around the country just
saw the meeting that we had today I
think what we are seeing is a great deal
of enthusiasm and energy for a campaign
designed to transform the way we do
economics and politics in America when
this started yet a bunch of people
working for you knew them all you
probably interviewed them all I bet you
now have people working on this campaign
you never met
oh absolutely what's that feel like well
you know it's the way it is one of the
problems and it's a very good problem to
have is that as our support multiplies
and as we have you know hundreds of
thousands of volunteers out there we
need a political infrastructure an
organizational capability that can
mobilize those folks in an effective way
now that means hiring a lot of people so
we got a lot of people in I want we all
a lot of people New Hampshire we're
hiring people in South Carolina and
we're going to be hiring people for
Super Tuesday states as well what are
the odds here the Democratic nominee
getting better every day okay last
question I interviewed a lot of people
out front people come in to your
fundraiser today and asome said you're
here for supporting Bernie Sanders you
don't support Hillary Clinton complete
this sentence fill in the blanks bernie
is blank hillary is blank how would you
complete that Bernie has throughout his
political career stood up and fought for
working families and has been prepared
to take on the wealthiest people in this
country and the most powerful special
interests
I'll let Hillary Clinton fill in the
blank for herself all right you should
watch what your supporters said their
answers were pretty interesting I think
you might have briefed them all before
they walked in because they were right
on message senator thank you appreciate
it thanks very much good luck